the the gas combustion people they're
how much they're in an uproar about the
Tesla like they're making fake videos
about how cheap the Tesla is and they're
pushing down on the dashboard and
they're adding all of these these sound
effects they have to do something
because they're so fast and
what's funny is they look at them they
look boring they don't look fast and
then no matter what they do to their car
this dude you see the new one
that's coming out 0 to 150 mil an hour
in 10 seconds first of all why would you
give somebody that's going to be texting
while D they're driving a missile the
thing's a missile so now everybody's
like what would you rather do have pizza
in the microwave or in a brick oven like
that somebody came up with that analogy
now everybody's saying it they can't
handle the fact that something that
makes no noise and doesn't look cool is
just blowing by
there driving down the it's
hilarious